ils sont arrivés pour leur tournée
française le 23 février dernier le
lendemain il se réveillait pour
découvrir avec effroi que leur pays
était attaqué par la russie les danseurs
et danseuses du québec city ballet donné
leur dernière représentation de
casse-noisette hier à tours un vrai
moment de féerie en ces temps troublés
regardez
[Musique]
l'histoire est celle de clara une jeune
fille qui la veille de noël reçoit un
cadeau de son nom un casse-noisette en
bois
[Applaudissements]
le jouet se transforme en prince après
avoir combattu le roi des souris les
deux amoureux sont alors transportés
dans un univers magique peuplé de
poupées sous les yeux ébahis des petits
et grands les croustilles
basculer parce que les tuyaux et aidé
rien
les décors et les dents c'était très
beau
ce conte d'hoffmann furet adapté par
alexandre dumas en 1844
c'est cette version qui a inspiré
tchaïkovski pour composer ce bal est
devenu si célèbre sur scène donc une
troupe de 30 artistes ukrainiens dansent
sur une musique écrite par un russe tout
un symbole c'est très dur
émotionnellement parce qu'on doit faire
bonne figure sur scène et sourire mais
on est des professionnels et on doit
faire avec
malheureusement aujourd'hui on ne peut
pas rentrer chez nous en ukraine c'est
un véritable défi quotidien car tout le
monde est très stressé
on ne dort pas beaucoup
et c'est très difficile de garder le
moral
aller sur scène répéter danser alors que
tout est si sombre
en résidence au théâtre du châtelet à
paris depuis le 23 février
il s'agissait de la dernière
représentation de casse-noisette en
france par le kiev city ballet